Bienvenidos a cultura hoy nos acompaña
Fernanda trías escritora uruguaya y
autora de novelas como la azotea o mugre
Rosa actualmente Fernanda reside en
Bogotá y es también a profesora de
creación literaria y escritora residente
en la universidad de los Andes
bienvenida Muchas gracias Alba
Fernanda en mugre Rosa nos cuentas como
su protagonista a través de una especie
de pandemia o una peste que llega por un
viento tóxico que no se sabe muy bien De
dónde viene pero que es letal
nos describes un panorama totalmente
distópico Por qué cuentas este tipo de
historias o en qué están inspiradas
Bueno este fue una incursión en este
género por primera vez digamos no Y eso
también fue un desafío interesante que
yo quería abordar como la construcción
desde la ficción de todo un universo
nuevo un mundo con otra fotografía con
otros este con otra organización
política
donde tenés que inventar hasta el nombre
de las cosas no eso me pareció
fascinante como Aventura creativa y en
realidad todo empezó este a partir de un
interés cada vez mayor
por el tema de la crisis Ambiental de la
crisis ecológica que poco a poco ese
tema fue afectándome en mi vida diaria
yo Ya llevaba años teniendo como mucha
angustia al respecto después me enteré
que no soy la única que incluso hay un
nombre que se le ha dado desde el
psicoanálisis a estas a este tipo de
angustia existencial Que está
relacionada con la crisis medioambiental
que se le llama en inglés eco ansiedad
este mi traducción no
y qué y que tiene que ver con esto no
con esta sensación de impotencia que las
personas individuales sentimos ante ante
la crisis ambiental entonces a partir de
eso después de muchos años tenía
pesadillas recurrentes este y a mí me
gusta hacer eso no como a partir de
cosas que me atraviesan como persona
tomarlas y empezar a investigarlas a
explorarlas en la escritura no Entonces
en este mundo distópico ha habido una
crisis una catástrofe ambiental que no
se explica que no se sabe que la originó
Pero podemos ver sus repercusiones y
dentro de digamos y esas repercusiones
han transformado el mundo y este lo que
a mí me interesaba era ver cómo esto
podía cambiar la vida de las personas
individuales comunes no este y bueno
este a partir de ahí empieza poquito a
poco a tejer la historia muy bien y
tanto en mugre Rosa como en la azotea
que fue así como tu primera novela
describes en los espacios exteriores
como sitios peligrosos y también hay
otro factor que a mí me llama mucho la
que es que hablas mucho sobre la
enfermedad y la salud es un tema que
está muy presente en tus novelas hay
alguna intencionalidad detrás de estas
dos cosas son temas sí que realmente me
siempre me han interesado este en
luego yo noté yo no me daba cuenta el
momento de escribir esta gran
coincidencia de que tanto la azotea como
mugre Rosa hay una hay un momento en que
la protagonista que es en los dos casos
son mujeres deciden encerrarse
encerrarse para buscar protección pero
evidentemente en la azotea La amenaza es
más imaginaria
Es todo es una cuestión que ocurre en la
mente de ella digamos y encuentra ese
mundo amenazante y se encierra en el
núcleo que considera seguro ya en mugre
Rosa yo siento y que la amenaza deja de
ser imaginaria pasa a ser real y que sea
afuera
es este de verdad
un espacio hostil amenazante del que hay
que resguar
y es cierto también que si vienen la
azotea como mi interés particular era
más con la enfermedad mental con la
paranoia como esta mujer va este en
peliculándose cada vez más al punto de
este de impactar fuertemente la vida de
su familia y obviamente la propia
en mugre Rosa otra vez ya deja de ser
metafórico pasa a ser mucho más literal
y está este viento contaminado que
cuando sopla si te toca
te infecta Y si te infecta produce una
serie de reacciones en la piel no este
entonces ahí el como es por la piel
la enfermedad el cuerpo está muy
presente no el cuerpo es algo que
realmente doloroso no me gustaba como
explorar la metáfora de estar en carne
viva o estar a flor de piel no donde
todo se siente mucho más
y para mí también en tu obra en general
hay dos temas que son fundamentales y es
la naturaleza humana y las relaciones
interpersonales tanto familiares como de
pareja por ejemplo en la azotea lo vemos
con la relación de Clara con su padre y
en mugre rosa con la de la protagonista
tanto con su exmarido como con su madre
y bueno son unas relaciones marcadas por
la dependencia es esto un tema también
fundamental o que marca tus libros Sí en
realidad este si hay está atravesado o
sea lo que siempre me más me a mí
fascinado en la naturaleza humana y la
naturaleza de las relaciones afectivas
no como dentro de las relaciones
afectivas y dentro del núcleo familiar
por ejemplo o con tu con tus padres con
tu hija con tu con tus afectos este el
esposo en el caso de mugre Rosa
se juegan todos los escenarios que luego
también podemos ver a nivel Macro no
juegos de poder hay juegos de crueldad
pero también amor pero entonces el amor
puede ser completamente enfermizo
digamos y entonces todas esas sutilezas
a mí siempre me ha fascinado
pensarlas no irlas trabajando en el
texto y
en el en la azotea y claramente un miedo
muy grande a perder no este Sí claro la
historia es fuerte porque ella empieza
como a perder la cabeza Pero en el fondo
es algo muy humano que todos hemos
sentido y es un amor tan grande por ese
ser querido que este nos lleva a tener
un pánico tal de perder que somos
capaces de hacer cualquier cosa para
intentar resguardar ese esa relación
digamos Ese es realmente en el fondo es
así no luego si eso lo llevo al extremo
y se vuelve completamente enfermizo se
puede convertir en algo brutal y cruel y
en mugre Rosa nuevamente estaba pensando
ese tema hay una que atraviesa toda la
novela que es la del elástico Y ella
dice que se encuentra
atada a su ex pareja por un elástico que
en la medida en que ella intenta
alejarse el elástico llega a su máxima
expansión y la devuelve con fuerza hacia
eso Y entonces aunque ella quiere romper
no puede pero también con la madre tiene
ese tipo de relación de elástico y yo
pensaba Sí claro es que esas son las
relaciones codependientes no intentar
alejarme no poder y en realidad la
novela a lo largo de la novela una de
las cosas que a mí me interesaba era ver
si ella iba a lograr romper con eso no
en el medio de esta situación
catastrófica que está afectando a todo
el país
si van a lograr romper con estas
relaciones O sea al contrario la
catástrofe los iba a acercar y los iba a
mantener este ya indefectiblemente
Unidos
y también otro rasgo que que yo aprecio
en tu obra es las voces femeninas no
todas tus protagonistas suelen ser
mujeres hay una también intencionalidad
quieres como enfrentar ahí
una visión femenina en tus obras no sé
si intencionalidad pero sí me sale
natural es decir siempre desde la
primera cosa que escribí la voz cuando
la trabajo en primera persona me sale de
un personaje femenino digamos no se me
ocurre por algún motivo Será porque mi
experiencia vital está atravesada por el
hecho de ser mujer
que nunca se me ocurre escribir
este un personaje protagónico hombre con
en primera persona ahora creo que sí se
puede hacer No es que crea que no se
puede hacer lo que pasa es que que me
interesan esos personajes femeninos Son
son muy poderosos no O sea sí son este
son complejos son oscuros muchas veces y
difíciles no son mujeres este
estereotípicas no
y en realidad
Este sí para mí eso es importante Ahora
si me preguntas yo nunca lo hago de una
manera muy planificada me va saliendo
así este y poco a poco Voy construyendo
el personaje lo voy entendiendo le voy
agregando capas de complejidad y mi
intención siempre es tratar de hacer a
la protagonista lo más este 3D posible
no lo más lo más este complejo porque la
naturaleza humana es compleja totalmente
y tu lenguaje también sobre todo en esta
última novela en mugre rosa es muy
poético allá hay alguna inspiración con
concreta para yo quería como digamos
como el mundo atmosférico muro de rosas
tan
sofocante en el sentido de que hay una
atmósfera
neblinosa constantemente está neblina
está esta sensación de oscuridad porque
el sol no atraviesa las nubes y
obviamente la situación se va
deteriorando y es ominoso todo lo que
está pasando al contrario yo quería que
contrastara con una con una mirada y un
lenguaje mucho más cristalino mucho más
Este incluso poético dentro de esa de
esa cosa terrible que estamos viendo que
estamos viviendo dentro de la novela
este porque me parecía que eso es lo que
permitía también que El lector pudiera
respirar dentro de la novela ya si no
eran la historia por lo menos fuera con
el lenguaje y luego este también
pensando la Lo poético como un espacio
de resistencia de esa Digamos como que
cada vez más estoy pensando que que la
poesía este sigue es y va a seguir
siendo más en esta época de Inteligencia
artificial donde los Bots te pueden
escribir la novela qué es lo que va
quedando
la poesía sigue siendo ese lugar de
resistencia donde Todavía este lo más
humano
este sigue siendo lo lo valioso no lo
importante
y he escuchado que estás trabajando en
una nueva novela si quieres nos puedes
comentar te queda un poco estoy estoy
este estoy trabajando también estoy
también sigo en esa búsqueda de pero
también Lo poético o el lenguaje más
poético obviamente no soy poeta me
gustaría hacerlo pero no no nunca fui
nunca escribí poesía este también nos
acerca a lo indecible no
cuando hay cosas que no no hay palabras
para decirlas la poesía es lo único que
puede acercar ahí y estoy escribiendo
una novela desde que terminé murasa
desde 2020
donde sigo esperando el tema de la
naturaleza
donde sigo explorando ciertos temas de
violencias hacia los cuerpos de las
mujeres este y hacia el cuerpo de la
naturaleza no
y también hago una búsqueda y del
lenguaje este para
ver también Digamos como escritora lo
que me interesa a mí es que cada libro
sea una experiencia no solo para el
lector una experiencia distinta y única
sino también para mí como escritora este
en lugar no me interesa tanto repetir
una fórmula si algo ya me salió sí Sino
ver bueno Y ahora cómo salgo de mi zona
de Confort y que puedo encontrar si
busco por este lado donde nunca me metí
Entonces en ese desafío siempre todo
puede salir mal pero si no sale mal
poder llegar a un lugar este distinto
que que desconocías incluso de tu propia
imaginación de tus propias emociones no
Y eso para mí lo bonito de la escritura
Muchas gracias Fernanda por estar aquí
con nosotros Gracias y a ustedes Muchas
gracias por acompañarnos y Para más
información pueden seguirnos en France
24 y France 24.com